let's take a quick look at how we would
use device motion to implement another
common mechanism the shake to send
feedback feature detecting a shake is
actually pretty easy we just register an
event listener for device motion an
inside our event handler we calculate
the squares of all of the accelerations
in all three directions and then test to
see how big that absolute some is if we
get a large value here we know we've hit
a shake so we can demonstrate that on
the screen if we wanted to be fancy we
might want to some these values over an
interval of time so slower motion that
goes on for longer would still trigger
it or we might want to add rotation into
the sum but in practice this will work
pretty well let's take a look